[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
fois aux questions qui stoppe science
foire aux questions pour laquelle
j'accueille aujourd'hui katia 12 katia
bonjour julien donc katia tué chercheuse
en préhistoire africaine au laboratoire
d'archéologie et peuplements de
l'afrique de l'université de genève en
suisse est ta spécialité c'est l'étude
de la cognition humaine l'origine de la
cognition humaine à partir de
l'archéologie lithiques donc à partir de
ce que les hommes préhistoriques
fabriqué en pierre les outils les
pierres taillées et c'est donc
aujourd'hui vous l'aurez compris c'est
un épisode qui va pas se consacrer à la
paléontologie mais à l'archéologie rond
on laisse tomber un peu l'homme en tant
qu'animal et on s'attaque à l'homme en
tant que producteur d'artefacts
puisqu'il puisqu'il faut savoir que le
les fossiles et notamment les fossiles
qu'on peut avoir de la boîte crânienne
ne nous permettent pas de comprendre le
fonctionnement du cerveau lui-même
puisqu'il ne s'agit pas de cerveau
fossilisé mais simplement de la cavité
crânienne du moulage à terme de la
cavité crânienne et même si on avait un
cerveau fossilisé de toute façon on ne
verrait pas les neurones fonctionner
donc on ne comprendrait pas comment ils
fonctionnent donc pour comprendre
l'origine de la cognition humaine
moderne il faut se pencher sur les
produits de l'intelligence et s'est
produit il ya ce sont les arts les
artefacts que tu étudies donc première
question déjà quel est le principe de
base comment on un fer de la de
l'intelligence à partir de pierres
taillées
alors d'abord
on n'aime pas beaucoup parler
d'intelligence pour pour ces périodes là
et surtout l'intelligence et un terme
assez difficile à définir
on parle plutôt justement de compétition
comme tu l'as dit un peu plus tôt
notamment parce qu'elle implique des
concepts de planification des étapes
d'actions qui sont qui sont qui peuvent
être plus ou moins nombreuses pour
obtenir donc des outils lithiques ce qui
est quand même le but en effet de ses
tailleurs de pierres alors dans le
principe ce qu'on étudie en tant que
l'éthicien c'est en effet d'où
proviennent d'abord donc les matières
premières qui peuvent provenir de
sources lointaines où justement dessous
qu'il ya beaucoup de matières premières
différentes et seulement une va être
sélectionné donc là vraiment on
identifier un premier choix dans cette
chaîne opératoire d'action pour obtenir
ces outils à la fin à la à la fin des
étapes de taille et ensuite il ya
plusieurs plusieurs méthodes de taille
qu'on essaie d'identifier donc en en
regardant ces industries lithiques et
ses méthodes sont assez spécifique
autant à travers le temps que dans
l'espace
et c'est à partir de ces méthodes
souvent qu'on identifie différentes
cultures différents savoir-faire qui
peuvent fortement différer en
chronologie mais aussi donc comme je le
disais tout à la vente dans l'espace et
bien sûr le but final de toutes ces
méthodes employées de tous ses choix
vous fait dans les matières premières
c'est l'obtention des outils à la fin
qui vont servir à différentes actions
qui peuvent être à la fois pour la
chasse donc là on est dans les sphères
de pointes de projectiles ou deux en
tout cas de d'éléments manche et le plus
souvent jusqu'aux des outils plutôt
domestique comme des racloirs des
grattoirs pour gratter dépôt pour
rappeler les pots mais aussi d'aider
couteau pour couper les viandes et ce
genre de choses mais également toute une
panoplie d'outils qui vont pas forcément
être retouchée c'est à dire que les
produits de cette taille de la pierre ne
m'ont pas forcément être transformé
puisque les bords brut de certains de
ces produits peuvent très bien servir
comme outil de manière brute et donc
c'est toute cette sphère là qu'on essaye
de reconstituer à partir de d'assemblage
mythique donc c'est ce qu'on retrouve
sur les sites archéologiques et qui
représentent en général des milliers de
pièces certaines qui vont être plus
caractéristique que d'autres et c'est
une sorte de puzzle en bref n'accordant
c'est une quantité de travail
c'est assez impressionnante et alors si
j'ai bien compris le mot clé c'est
planification ça c'est la planification
de la représentation que se sont faits
les hominidés de cette époque
donc on parle d' homo sapiens là ça
concerne que homo sapiens oui en tout
cas ça c'est les périodes sur lesquels
je travaille qui sont donc
principalement occupés on va dire en
tout cas les outils de cette période
sont fabriqués par les homo sapiens qui
ou en forme peut être transitoire entre
les formes de notes d'homininés plutôt
erectus détresse des élèves tous très
récent vers l'homo sapiens et à prédire
il ya trop peu de reste pour vraiment
dire qui a fait ces industries en tout
cas autour de 200 mille ans on n'est pas
tout à fait sûr même si au travers le
temps vers la fin de cette période qui
s'appelle donc le mezzo stone age à
laquelle je travaille à la fin de la
période de vingt mille ans là on est
très sûr qu'on a des homo sapiens
anatomiquement pleinement moderne
d'accord donc ces gens là étaient
capables donc de se dire qu'il ne je
j'ai besoin d'un caillou qui vient de
tels endroits
j'ai besoin de le préparer de telles
façons pour faire pour achever cette
tâche particulièrement et c'est cette
chaîne donc de de planification qui vous
permet de dire est là et la complexité
de cette chaîne de planification qui
vous permet de dire de dire s'il y a
khan était le
niveau je ne sais pas je sais pas si
jean paul moka but là mais quel était le
niveau de cognition oui alors il y à
certains niveaux de condition qu'on peut
déjà qui est très commun à tout le monde
en tout cas dès qu'on parle des homo
sapiens anatomiquement modernes on a
tous le même niveau de commissions après
c'est comment ils utilisent qui est qui
qui est intéressant et quand on parle
par exemple de complexité dans les
actions de taille
ça veut pas dire que ce groupe là qui a
peut-être une chaîne opératoire très
compliquées entre avec des sources de
matières premières très lointaine avec
des prises de risque pendant la taille
qui est qui et qui est peut-être même
pour nous parfois absurde avec des
outils esthétiquement très développé ça
ne veut pas dire que ce groupe là va
avant un niveau cognitif qui est plus
élevé qu'un autre groupe qui va juste à
être capable de s'adapter avec d'adapter
ses méthodes de taille aux matières
premières qui trouve localement donc ils
s'embêtent pas aller les chercher très
loin mais il a une méthode qui qui qui
part à très exigeante qui permet
d'exploiter des blocs de manière locale
et c'est vrai que d'un point de vue
technique c'est c'est cette adaptation
peut paraître un peu moins standardisés
puisqu'en forcément on joue avec les
règles de la physique puisque ça va pas
être et les mêmes matières premières ça
va pas être les matières premières de
premier choix donc parfois ils vont
regarder accident
s'adapter donc si on retrouve cette
deuxième ensemble qui va me paraître
beaucoup plus moins exigeants pour les
plus opportunistes et tout ça sinon si
on ne savait pas contemporain à notre
groupe on le pense très peut-être
beaucoup plus vieux et apparaît étant le
fait de dominer qui avait a priori des
capacités cognitives qui était beaucoup
moins développés mais en fait finalement
ce les datations me permettent de
montrer cette contemporanéité et dire
que d'un point de vue cognitif ces
personnes sont totalement égal et c'est
là on rentre en jeu l'aspect culturel de
ce qu'on peut dire sur sur ces groupes
d'homo sapiens est ce qui nous aussi ce
qui nous oblige aussi à ne pas donner
forcément de valeur de valeur
différentiel sur sur les comportements
justement de différents groupes
c'est difficile de dire que quelque
chose est plus efficace parce que qu'est
ce qu'on en sait finalement peut-être
qu'ils utilisaient pas de la manière
dont on utiliserait on peut pas dire que
c'est beaucoup plus complexe parce que
peut-être qu'ils avaient aussi des
sociétés qui sont immatérielles et que
l'on retrouve pas qui était peut-être
qu'il y avait une complexité qui était
plus grande que d'autres groupes qui
matériellement est plus complexe
donc finalement cédé terme avec lesquels
on jongle avec lesquels il faut aussi
faire votre attention les termes de
complexité d'efficacité de
d'intelligence justement parce que c'est
un concept très parfois aussi très
actually ce tu ne te parle de
différences culturelles
on voit déjà des différences culturelles
au sein de l'afrique
il y a entre 100000 et
vingt mille ans donc c'est ça ta période
de prédilection donc il ya entre 100000
et 20 mille ans on voit déjà des
différences culturelles entre
différentes régions africaines
absolument alors on parle de différences
culturelles
c'est un peu large mais en fait vu que
nous on travaille sur nés sur les restes
et l'éthique où on va dire que c'est
techno culturel c'est une culture qu'on
définit à partir des techniques et de la
technologie
donc on appelle ça des technoculture est
en effet le début du mai de stone age
donc qui est cette période qui
m'intéresse mais qui en fait trop monte
à 300 mille ans à peu près de 300 mille
après mille ans avec l'homo sapiens qui
arrive autour de 160 mille ans à peu
près donc qui n'est pas là au début du
mai de stone age mais le met de stone
age
culturellement techno culturellement est
déjà présent c'est très intéressant
parce que une des premières grandes
synthèses qui a été fait surnommer de
soleil
en tout cas pour l'afrique de l'est mark
clark en 1988 appelle cette synthèse le
gaming et john linehan city ça veut dire
que le mytho stone age c'est vraiment le
moment où commence une espèce de
différenciation d'identité culturelle
selon les régions et même à des échelles
microrégionale ce qu'on ne trouve pas
vraiment avant le mes de stone age ou
même si la jeunesse est à nuancer
évidemment mais on voit à peu près
partout en afrique des industries qui
sont qui partent des mêmes principes de
technologique et donc le met deux
collèges introduit notamment aux salles
des outils phares qui sont souvent les
pointes des caractéristiques qui sont
bien assez bien marquer régionalement et
qui nous permettent en effet de
l'identifier
différents groupes ou différentes
formations contemporaine mais aussi on
voit ces différences aussi à travers le
temps donc on peut absolument voir des
différences culturelles au sein du mais
de stonehenge médias semaines avant que
l'homo sapiens arrive d'accord donc à
partir de quand ce serait quoi la note
enfin la date qui est retenu en général
c'est au tour de trois cent mille ans
parce que c'est plutôt basé sur des sur
des séquences qu'on connaît pour
l'afrique de l'est parce qu'en général
dans les autres régions cette période là
et pas trop hein as tu y aller on donne
plus davantage aux périodes un peu plus
récente du mais de stone age on est sûr
qu'il est homo sapiens où il commence à
faire des industries qui sont peut-être
un peu plus
je vais utiliser le terme complexe mais
en tout cas qui sont un peu plus
standardisés ou qu'on arrive à mieux
tracer dans l'espace comme ceux qu'on
trouve en afrique du sud avec le style b
qui est caractérisée par des grandes
pointes sont pas très grandes d'ailleurs
mais peut-être 6,7 cm mais contre as
bien dans l'espace et qu'on voit bien
les limites de cette culture puisqu'elle
n'existe pas un pouce au nord à ce genre
de choses donc en tout cas cette période
ancienne on la connaît assez mal parce
qu'on la connaît qu régionalement mais
déjà dans cette région en afrique de
l'est
elle montre des différences donc pour ce
qui est de l'identité de ces hommes se
seraient de ce qu'on appelle les homo
sapiens archaïque forme archaïque
anatomiquement je parle bien évidemment
oui oui il ya aussi une appellation que
je pense qu'il n'est pas beaucoup
utilisé mais qui existe quand même aussi
c'est au monde elle mail et qui aussi
est en fait une forme de mon sapiens
archaïque mais qui aussi une sorte de
fourre-tout pour tous les homos sapiens
qui sont qui occupe à qui il manque
quelques caractères anatomiquement
modernes et qui en fait d'un squelette à
l'autre ou d'un reste un autre montre
une certaine variabilité
donc ça c'est au niveau de l'industrie
lithique et du coup est ce qu est ce qu
on voit au niveau de l'éthique
une agente d'émergence de sens de la
beauté
est-ce qu'on voit des objets qui ont été
taillés juste pour être beau parce que
ça ça se trouve en afrique alors c'est
une question très intéressante qui
évidemment touche une sphère qui est en
dehors de la technologie de la technique
et des savoir faire ce qu'on a
l'habitude plutôt de reconstruire dans
cette sphère symbolique
on dira pas ce que c'est la beauté
forcément un symbole c'est fait pour
être vu c'est une utilité plutôt social
ou en afrique
comment je crois en en europe il ya
surtout ces pièces qui sont bifaciales
qu'on appelle souvent les bifaces qui
est certaine une certaine symétrie tels
que qu'elles sont parfois considérés
comme des oeuvres d'art qu'on se demande
parfois si l'utilité n'a pas
s'ils ne se mélangent pas parfois aussi
avec du symbolique mais c'est
probablement pas forcément par les
industries lithiques on peut découvrir
le plus sur cette sphère 109 symbolique
en tout cas cette l'émergence
éventuellement d'une pensée symbolique
et c'est plutôt à partir des autres
reste qu'on trouve donc en association à
ces assemblages éthique dans les sites
ou les matières organiques sont bien
préservés par exemple avec ces autres
restes qui sont trop grandes
associations qu'on peut discuter de
satisfaire symbolique et notamment en
afrique du sud
l'exemple peut être le plus le plus
marquant est probablement ce bout doc
requis et quelques centimètres de long
et un peu étroit qui a été retrouvé dans
le site de plans moss autour de 80 mille
ans et qui lui a été gravé avec des
symboles symétrique alors là
géométriques en tout cas c'est d'être
plutôt ses gravures géométriques qui on
a beau chercher une peuvent ne semble
pas vraiment elle pouvoir être associé à
quelque chose de qui est purement une
utilitaire et ce serait donc là peut
être la plus anciens vraiment fort ou
deux on parlera pas d'art on parlera
d'esthétique ou de beauté mais en tout
cas il y à un symbole sûr sûr sûr cette
offre pied qui est très clair et aussi
pour cette même période on retrouve tu
parle de période la note
la date c'est on va dire que ça commence
autour de 120 mille ans et ça c'est
ensuite sur des périodes plus récente
mais je suis généreuse quand je dis ça
m'a mis là on dira peut-être plutôt cent
mille ans quand les bulldogs en question
et 900 millions dont il a 81 millions et
c'est intéressant parce que dans le même
site autour de 5000 ans justement on a
trouvé probablement les plus anciennes
contenant dans des coquillages des
avalon des grand coquillage en nacre est
très beau et dont il y en a au moins
deux qui ont été publiées jusqu'à
maintenant qu'ils ont été avérés comme
étant des contenants pour la fabrication
de pâte à base d'encre avec un complexe
avec un mélange complexe c'est à dire
avec un apport de deux minéraux moulu
notamment de quartz cake qui a été
envoyée pardon oui qui a été rajouté
donc dans cette cette composition a pas
d'offre probablement aussi avec des
traces de graisse et ce genre de choses
et qui a été retrouvée aussi en
association avec une scapula d'
de phoque notamment qui probablement
servi à travailler ses composantes
d'autres mais là encore c'est assez une
découverte assez exceptionnel qui nous
permet de dire qu'il ya qu il y a une
pensée assez complexe dans le sens où il
faut savoir qu'un mélange
quelles sont les composantes qu'on veut
rajouter un mélange mais en même temps
on connaît pas à quoi ça a servi ça a pu
servir à peindre ça a pu servir à
recouvrir les pots pour la beauté ou
pour pour repousser les insectes par
exemple les moustiques ça ça apparemment
ça marche très très bien les les pâtes à
base d'offres pour repousser les
moustiques ça donc ça peut être à la
fois symbolique au fonctionnel là avec
vous d'autres qu'on la retrouve de vingt
mille ans plus tard avec les gravures
géométriques
là on est par contre vraiment à quelque
chose qui serait vraiment plus tôt dans
la sphère du symbolique
même si bien sûr peut-être qu'on se
trompe complètement ensuite il y as pour
la même période autour de 80 mille ans
on découvre aussi dans plusieurs sites
en afrique du sud mais aussi en afrique
du nord
des coquillages verser
intentionnellement et qui ont des traces
d'usures à l'endroit où ils ont été
percés donc on peut des traces d'usure
qui dès polissage qui ont été laissées
par parler est probablement le lien le
clic qui permettait de garder ces
coquillages ensemble et qui sert elle a
par contre en effet pu enfin très
fortement symbolique même
est utilisé comme parure et
ornementation peut-être aussi pour des
pour différencier des groupes des
différents groupes là on revient à
l'identité culturelle et qui qui peut à
votre du coup aussi utilitaire puisque
ça permet de différencier éventuellement
certains groupes entre eux d'accord donc
en fait le deuxième mot clé pour deviner
la cognition là dans le cas du sens de
la beauté on va dire ce serait
l'inutilité c'est simple si c'est si ces
utilitaires ses utilitaires du coup ça
veut dire que c'était voilà que c'était
bassement matérielles mais quand ça
devient inutile alors là ça veut dire
qu'il y a peut-être un sens symbolique
derrière et peut-être une juste une
volonté esthétique mais déjà ça veut
dire qu'il y a plus que simplement la
volonté de survivre ou deux
et comme je disais tout à l'heure c'est
très possible que certains certains
outils même à l'éthique ou des objets
très bassement à qui nous paraissent
très très comment et pas du tout investi
ont une charge symbolique qu'on est
absolument incapable de voir ce que nous
on connaît du symbolique et c'est ce que
l'on connaît actuellement pour notre
propre société mais aussi des sociétés
qui sont toujours deux jours observable
en ethnographie il y a peut être
d'autres de d'autres combinaisons qu'on
ne connaît pas du tout capable de voir
et c'est assez marrant il ya une étude
dans les années 70 sur france 2 peut
être qu'un il me semble sûre
lénine irait en jahia l'indonésie et qui
faisait des haches polies et donc pour
des fins archéologie qui pour comprendre
comment était fabriquée ch tholy et
quelles étaient les possibilités
techniques pour fabriquer ces haches
polies
ils ont fait donc une étude am non
archéologiques ce qu'on appelle l'aide
noir qui est logique email l'ethnologie
à des fins archéologiques et ils ont
découvert que ce qui était d'être
réforme de l'âge donc très grossièrement
et carys était en fait les objets les
plus rituels et les plus symboliques
dans cette société alors que les âges
pour lee qui était parfaitement finies
et parfaitement symétrique parfaitement
poli
elle était purement utilitaire parce que
si elle n'était pas pour lui
parfaitement elle n'était plus en plus à
même à se briser ou à s'abîmer
rapidement pendant leur utilisation donc
des fois c est maintenant être newark nj
et cette technologie nous aide beaucoup
à prendre du recul sur ce que nous on
considère comme l'utilitaire est ce que
nous on considère comme symbolique mais
en général les premières formes de
d'inutilité ou en tout cas d'inutilité
qui se mêle à une possible utilisation
est plutôt identifié autour de 2 80
mille ans je dirais aux cent mille ans
au maximum pour l'instant quand donc
sans milan se serait l'apparition d'une
d'une pensée symbolique esthétique est
ce qu'on a dit est-ce qu'on a des
peintures rupestres qui date à peu près
de cette époque
en tout cas en afrique non mais je vais
juste revenir sur l'émergence de cette
pensée symbolique c'est l'émergence de
l'identification notre notre capacité à
identifier cette france est symbolique
qui existe est peut-être déjà j'insiste
mais qu'on la voie d'un point de vue
matériel qu'à partir de environ 5000 ans
mais en tout cas pour tout ce qui est
ensuite il ya une autre étape dans en
effet comme tout comme tu le dit dans
dans la pensée symbolique ou dans
l'expression de la pensée symbolique qui
est celle de la figuration
c'est à dire la figuration humaine ou
animale en effet au travers des
délinquants pestre ce genre de choses ça
en afrique
la plus vieille l'appliquer ce concours
est le plus vieux vestiges coin qui a
été reconnue jusqu'à maintenant et celui
d'apollo 11 en namibie autour de 30
millions 25000 donc beaucoup plus tard
virer tardivement que certaines traces
que l'on peut retrouver en europe de
manière contemporaine mais c'est pas
parce qu'on est déjà l'homo sapiens en
afrique que directement
il fait automatiquement de l'art
rupestre peu ce qu'on pourrait
s'attendre en effet de voir défiler des
traces figurative autour de cent mille
ans lorsque l'homo sapiens
anatomiquement modernes et est vraiment
bien l'exprimer et qu'il exprime d'autre
part d'autres formes de pensée
symbolique au travers de l'orientation
comme je disais ou des des figures
géométriques que l'on retrouve sur ce
bout doc remet aussi un tout petit peu
plus tard en verve 68 milan 65 mille ans
sur des coquilles d'oeuf de truffes dans
d'autres
assemblage meadows stone age et dans un
même sens en en afrique de l'est où
l'homo sapiens anatomiquement modernes a
été découvert et où il est le plus vieux
ils sont 95 mille cent soixante mille
ans arrrgh tôt et à
aumont qui vivent là par contre pour
quasiment tout le monde est stone age
il existe aucune forme ou très peu de
vestiges de pensée symbolique alors que
là par contre on a vraiment cette
présence de sapiens très claire alors
que l'afrique du sud on a très peu de
restes d'homo sapiens mais par contre on
a beaucoup une abondance de ces vestiges
et qui témoigne de cette pensée
symbolique ça amusant ça que en afrique
de l'est donc on a on associe à la
vallée du rift est donc la naissance du
genre humain en général et donc cette
vallée du rift qui serait le berceau de
l'humanité finalement fin serait moins
le lieu de naissance de la pensée
symbolique que l'afrique du sud
c'est là où on en revient aux questions
est ce que la pensée symbolique
s'exprime forcément par dans le matériel
peut être qu'il ya une autre forme de
pensée symbolique ou peut-être qu'elles
n'étaient pas appliquées par sa part des
populations dans cet endroit là mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que d'un point de vue
anatomique qui sont très proches de nous
il qu'on peut considérer même s'il ya
une évolution depuis les les presque 200
mille ans qu'ils existent qu'il ya une
évolution dans le cerveau une évolution
neuronale éventuellement comme certains
le prétendent même si c'est absolument
impossible de le prouver ou quoi que ce
soit il est très possible que ces
personnes pour pour des raisons qu'ils
soient culturelles ou à l'atomic n'est
pas forcément appliqué les mêmes
principes
de symbolisme ceci dit la grosse
différence qu'il ya entre l'afrique du
sud et l'afrique du nord ou dans ces
deux régions on trouve ces vestiges qui
atteste cette pensée symbolique
donc d'un côté et de l'autre côté
l'afrique de l'est il n'ya barde pas ou
très peu de 2 c de ces vestiges là en
afrique du sud afrique de l'est
les sites qui sont découverts sont
généralement en grottes et en grotte en
abris sous roche
la préservation et des surtout des
restes organiques de tout ce qui est non
minérale donc en fait on doit des
vestiges lithiques sont très bien
conservés alors comme afrique de l'est
la plupart des sites sont découverts
donc en plein air et donc on retrouve en
général très peu de restaurants ganic
est très peu d'autres types de reste que
ce qui est des vestiges lithiques alors
en l'absence de ces restes est-ce qu'ils
étaient réellement absent à l'époque où
est-ce que ils sont juste pas parvenue
elle
ça c'est une question et quiconque
cherche évidemment à c'est un vide qu'on
essaye de combler c'est une question
qu'on essaye de d'aborder de régler en
quelques stars pour avoir un peu plus
d'éclat libre dans les différents
enregistrements dans ces différentes
régions d'afrique et pour raisonner sur
une échelle un peu plus transcontinental
d'accord donc ce serait il y aurait
possiblement un billet de préservation
oui alors puisqu'on parle de ces de ces
espèces de coquillages qui contenait de
locre en fait tu expliquer tout à
l'heure que cette offre ils n'étaient
pas faits n'étaient pas fait seulement
d'offres justement c'était vraiment une
recette pâtes complets de complexité
dans la
composition et dans le les ingrédients
qu'il faut mixer
est ce qu'on la retrouve dans d'autres
substances cette complexité de oui en
fait défection
voyez la complexité de confection
oui on l'a on la retrouva ailleurs alors
que c'est pas la patte qui est forcément
complexe c'est justement cette scène le
fait qu'il y ait une pensée derrière de
pouvoir transformer différentes matières
de les ajouter ensemble pouvant
fabriquer une autre et ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est qui qui l'on
reconnaît donc dans ces coquillages d'un
malone avec accès pâte à base d'ogm mais
ça c'est vraiment peut-être les
témoignages les plus anciens mais elle
retrouve aussi dans dans les
compositions de d'adhésifs d'être des
adhésifs qui sont fabriqués pour
l'embranchement des pièces dans qui
permet des amendements pour être tenu en
main mais qui peuvent être aussi des
embranchements pour pour que l'outil
soit sur rouleaux boudin javelot ou
d'une flèche et de la colle pour coller
les retailler au bout d'un bâton
voilà en gros ça et pierrot général et
on imagine fin ça peut qu'en général
accor surtout quand c'est des pièces un
peu large on les imagine pas tenir
seulement avec cet adhésif avec sept
cols mais en association avec des liens
végétaux qui sont créés enroulé autour
de cet angle avec la sauce de ce caillou
au bout comme tu dis qui permet de
tout ça bien ensemble a pour des
activités qui peuvent peut-être impliqué
des gestes amples violents ou des
impacts et c'est notamment le cas avec
les projectiles et donc dans ses résidus
c'est cette non on les retrouve donc
sous forme de résidus et ses résidus en
général sont en quantité assez minime
sur les pièces on en retrouve aussi pas
beaucoup enfin que les premières après
les plus anciennes qui sont un peu
systématique comme tout cas et bien
avéré c'est autour de 70 mille ans dans
une culture qui s'appelle ma progression
ce point est en afrique du sud on
retrouve des petits segments qui font à
peu près 3 maximum 3 cm de long et qui
sont assez étroit et qui sont
probablement en manche et en ou deux
peut-être de flash ou même d'un manche
différents pour une meilleure tenue en
main puissance et des outils très petit
c'est là dans cette culture là qu'on en
retrouve quand même assez régulièrement
et les quantités sont infimes
et donc ces adhésifs écoles on n'en
connaît pas forcément très bien la
composition ils peuvent se composé par
exemple d'une seule essence de grésigne
de plantes mais elle peut aussi avoir
des ajouts par exemple d'autres dans ce
mélange du col pour être en fortifier
les propriétés adhésives
jusqu'à combien d'ingrédients
retrouvez là dedans je sais pas vraiment
mais en général dans les dents les
ingrédients identifiable et de relais
voire au minimum de 3 4 degrés dian il
ya aussi de charbon qui peut qui peut
aussi être intégré dans ses pattes mais
sachant que du charbon qui peut se
retrouver très facilement doit avoir une
présence accidentelle puisque c'est les
adhésifs qui se chauffent et en général
ça décolle qui sont fabriqués en les
questions début autour de feu à
proximité de foyers donc il peut aussi
avoir des apports qui s'est plutôt
accidentelle de charbon donc après
évidemment comme pour tout il faut
toujours faire la différenciation aussi
on arrive à la faire entre ce qui est
accidentelle est ce qui est intentionnel
et je crois que 1 des mots clés qu'on
n'a pas encore abordé ici c'est
l'intentionnalité des de ce que l'on
retrouve sur les sites archéologiques au
général que ce soit sur des outils les
traces d'utilisation sont-elles
intentionnelle vraiment lié à
l'utilisation ces traces sont présentes
parce que il y à un écrasement des bords
qui n'était pas forcément intentionnel
qui peut laisser de traces et ça ce sont
des l'identification de
l'intentionnalité ça requiert des
spécialistes qui travaillent vraiment
très profonde et bien sûr sur ces sujets
comme comme tu expliquer qu'il pouvait y
avoir 4 4 même trois quatre ingrédients
plus du chauffage plus du bordage le
disais quand même ça
un certain niveau de connaissances de
compétences cette spécialité et d'un
toast d'intentionnalité du culture oui
absolument mais ce mot donc ouais il
avait quasiment des chimistes quoi des
spécialistes
parmi eux il ya soixante dix mille ans
pour fabriquer ce type d'outil pas pour
fabriquer ce type de 2 us qu'on appelle
a en fait des outils composite c'est à
dire qu'ils sont composés de plusieurs
éléments
et çà et là on en revient aux chaînes
opératoires à la planification
l'association de plusieurs un matériau
de plusieurs objets qui sont en plus
dans le cas en tout cas de la colle qui
proviennent eux mêmes déjà de tout un
processus de transformation
ça demande une chérie fais ratoire
énormément planifiées à l'avancé avec
une pensée abstraite de ce qu'on veut
obtenir et là on y est évidemment
totalement dedans dents lorsqu'on parle
d'art matières composites et de ce genre
de d'outils complexes un oui absolument
et c'est doux d'où le grand intérêt des
archéologues à essayer de retrouver
justement c'est des indices de cette
complexité de cette de ce coût de cet
aspect composite de cet aspect
transformer d'autres matériaux dans le
temps quoi essayer de les tracer au plus
vieux possible et en effet les dates ne
cesse de reculer pour les plus anciennes
découvertes
donc si on fait un petit résumé des mots
clés jusqu'à présent donc planification
inutilité et le dernier tu as dis donc
c'est
anciaux nalité donc déjà avec ces trois
mots clés là on a on a trois gros
indices qui nous permettent de
reconstituer la cognition chez chez chez
les hominidés en particulier chez homo
sapiens et ce depuis donc au moins 100
au maximum 100 mille ans mais il ya plus
d'un 10 qui datent de 70 mille ans 70 60
mille ans et là il ya quatrième
mots-clés qui me vient qui me vient à
l'esprit c'est langage parce qu' est-ce
que du coup tout puisqu'on parlait de la
chimie etc pour transmettre d'une
personne à une autre une quelque chose
d'aussi spécifique que la ses recettes
pour l'école ou la façon de fabriquer
les les pierres comme on les fabrique et
au middle stone age qui était un jeu
différent voilà moi dommage peut pas
fabriquer la même chose quoi va falloir
que quelqu'un m'explique
et du coup voilà c'est ça c'est là où je
veux en venir c'est que est-ce qu'il
s'expliquait les choses est ce que est
ce que découvrir tout ça implique
forcément qu'il s'expliquait les choses
et que du coup ils savaient parler oui
alors oui absolument cia indien où un
passage de savoir-faire de génération en
génération qui est très claire dans ce
sens là on peut aussi le voir on voit
cette processus là aussi en tout cas
pour ces adhésifs les écoles ces cols en
particulier dans les contacts et de
graphiques et il ya pas mal de travaux
qui ont été faits sur la namibie
justement il utilise ses cols
aujourd'hui est donc ça nous permet
d'avoir une idée de comment des écoles
ont été faites à l'époque et comment
elle s'intègre aussi dans un groupe est
en effet c'est
des activités étant vraiment spécialisés
ses activités spécialisées elle requiert
un savoir faire savoir faire technique
une expérience sa rigueur aussi de
savoir d'apprendre de ces accidents de
parfaire les mêmes erreurs et dans moins
d arc est logique quand on voit des
collections ou des connexions les tic
notamment même dans la taille de la
pierre où il ya très peu d'erreurs très
peu de d'accidents de taille des
techniques sont complètement maîtrisé on
peut absolument parler d'un savoir faire
qui a aussi été probablement transféré
et améliorer peut-être même aux autres
au cours du temps par les expériences
qui ont été faites par peut être des
ancêtres ou ou des couples voisins ou
même au sein d'un même groupe
on peut tout à fait imaginer qu'il y ait
en effet un langage
après il ya des études pour savoir quel
est le degré de complexité de ces
langages
est-ce que c'était langage simple avec
avec une communication qui est plutôt
gestuelle ou où est-ce qu'on se retrouve
là vraiment dans des sociétés où il ya
obligation d'avoir des langage articulé
complexe et ça nos points de vue
archéologique au c'est très difficile de
le dire au sein des linguistes heures on
dira que pour cette période là
l'hypothèse favoriser sa
plutôt une société où les gens ont
probablement une langue proche de la
langue clique qui parle est actuellement
en afrique australe et qui appartient à
un groupe de 12 hommes qui d'hommes et
de femmes et des allemands avec le
brouillage donc des personnes
voilà et donc c'est plus ou moins
l'hypothèse qui qui qui domine sachant
que ça aussi un progrès qu'il y ait une
continuation une continuation culturel
depuis le mes deux collègues jusqu'à
actuellement ce qui est quand même
difficile à à soutenir comme comme
équipe hôtesse il ya quand même 100
mille ans entrés ils ont aussi leur
histoire et peut-être aussi une histoire
de la langue qui a évolué donc il y a
probablement un langage un langage
absolument et on voit ça même notamment
aux stars des des sages de singe aussi
par exemple qui fonce apprendre les uns
des autres des choses et parfois même
des gestes et certains gestes et
techniques
d'accord mais justement savez rejoindre
une question du coût par homo sapiens
est pas le premier à fabriquer des
outils donc ouais éventuellement à
partir de quand on considère
considérerait quand grohl la fabrication
d'outils en pierre à la sophistication
entre guillemets de ces outils en pierre
implique qu'il y ait forcément eu
éducation transmission de savoir c'est
une très bonne question et je pense
qu'on n'est pas vraiment en mesure
directe pour moi c'est la transmission
du savoir en fait une invention
technique ne peut pas perdurer pendant
des millions d'années s'il n'y a pas de
transmission un certain nombre qui ya
toujours une forme de transmission après
à savoir quelle forme elle prend cette
transmission est ce que ça va être juste
comme je le disais tout à l'heure un
geste je montrais à répétition et qui va
être répétée
ensuite c'est un sort de transmission
assez simple ou est-ce que ça va être
une transmission qui implique aussi
l'histoire donc revenir dans le passé
sur les expériences passées
explication des accidents qui peut y
avoir et comment planifier dans les
gestes techniques que le fait que ces
accidents ne se passe pas de les éviter
ce genre de choses qui sont pas
forcément transmissibles de manière
facile juste en montrant des gestes ou
en faisant des langages qui bat complexe
des sceaux ou quoi c'est difficile c'est
difficile de savoir quand apparaît
peut-être un onglet tous plus complexe
je crois que ça pourrait peut-être être
à peu près sûrs au cours de la chaleur
je dirais donc bien à moi ça cent mille
ans mais là c'est pas mon domaine de
compétence et j'ai peur de dire des
bêtises ok maintenant si tu veux bien on
va attaquer une deuxième partie de cette
interview où on va un peu plus
s'intéresser à des des choses qui sont
passés dans l'actualité qui soit en
rapport avec le temps domaine et la
première c'est là une annonce qui a été
faite il ya pas longtemps à propos de
petits singes sud américain dès sa page
ou qui fabriquait des outils et en gros
ça s'est agité sur des réseaux sociaux
en disant que ben voila quoi les
archéologues et si ça se trouve ils se
sont plantés depuis le début est ce que
tu peux nous rassurer à ce sujet je
crois que ça va beaucoup à m
c'est que cette question là enfin que
cet engouement à la pour cette news pour
cet article qui sortit un décret a dû
faire hérisser les poils de mes
collègues qui travaillent sur les faces
les plus anciennes parce qu'en effet
s'attendre quand tu te dis à un peu
décrédibilisée ce qu'ils essayent de
montrer et qui est tout à fait ils ont
tout à fait raison je dirais que là on
en revient en fait la première page
de cette interview j'ai expliqué
justement les histoires de planification
mais aussi ce que je n'ai pas dit mais
il ya une certaine récurrence de
d'action technique qui se répètent
qu'ils se répètent et c7 systématique
aussi qui permet de dire c'est quelque
chose et intentionnelle ou pas ensuite
ce que font ces petits singes c'est
quelque chose de très très basique et en
effet si ces graisses ont retrouvé isolé
évidemment les l'archéologue ne les
considérait pas comme taillée par par
des homininés de quelque sorte que ce
soit ne voit pas il n'y a pas la
signature de cette planification dont tu
parles ya pas de cette signature la et à
mon avis ils font des gestes qui sont
très simples qui laisse forcément très
peu de stigmates sur sur les pierres des
stigmates qui sont probablement pas très
récurrent d'une pièce à l'autre et il
laisse pas non plus des assemblages
c'est-à-dire dd oui des ensembles de
d'artefacts politiques abondants sur le
même site
là c'est une expérience en fait c'est
quelque chose qu'on connaît depuis très
très longtemps qui pas du tout une
nouveauté sauf que là apparemment ça a
été décrit de manière un peu plus on va
dire systématique et plus contrôlée
risque pas nouveau c'est pas nouveau non
c'est pas ça n'a pas survécu au pas du
tout pas du tout surpris parce que ça
fait déjà depuis longtemps qu'on sait
que les sages
utilisent des outils pour casser des
noix pour pour faire même il y a même
certains je ne sais plus les cannes
c'est qu'ils utilisent des bâtons pour
chasser or au sein des grands singes et
donc là je veux dire c'est décédé c'est
des choses qui sont connues depuis
longtemps et qui sont notamment connu
par les gens qui travaillent beaucoup
sur justement l'identification de la
commission parce qu'on part doit partir
la plupart de ces études parts à partir
des buts avec les singes et les enfants
humains actuels de moins de deux ans
pour voir déjà évaluer quel est le
niveau de commissions il existe à la
vase et ensuite qu'ils sont comparés
donc au cours du temps et donc c'est
quelque chose qui est très étudiée déjà
depuis longtemps et qui peut ça peut la
question peut se poser sur les toutes
premières industries lithiques mais les
chercheurs qui travaillent sur ces
phases très très anciennes sont tout à
fait au courant qu'ils doivent être
absolument très rigoureux dans leur
diagnostic est évidemment quand ils
identifient de mes productions humaines
et qui ne sont donc pas qu'ils sont
probablement pas accidentel et qui sont
intentionnels
là c'est évidemment la première
choses qui disons à écarter ils nous
font très bien et ils savent très bien
ce qu'ils font et et il n'y a pas de y'a
pas se stresser on peut leur faire
confiance
comment ça se passe à quelque chose donc
elle ferait en fonction de l'utilité du
magic en fonction de l'utilité du coup
eu une différence des différentes façons
de tailler et du coup là c'est sage là
ils n'ont pas du tout la même utilité
avec leurs cailloux je crois qu'ils les
lèches il est classé une élève qui
disait dans l'article donc il n'ya pas
de va pas y avoir le même mode
opératoire pour aboutir à ce résultat la
queue pour aboutir justement une belle
pointe il faut mettre au goût d'une saga
absolument dans la poule pour le médian
stone age et a aucun souci c'est là je
parle vraiment parler des assemblages
qui ont des bleus plusieurs millions
d'années
et là la maison qui travaillent de mes
collègues qui travaillent sur ces
collections là doivent se défendre face
à ce genre de comparaison qui seront
tout à fait légitime mais ça nous pousse
aussi redéfinir nos critères et à être
d'autant plus exigeant dans nos études
et ce genre de choses et met en tout cas
c'est pas ce n'est pas une surprise est
en effet assez terrible ac il ya aussi
une plus grande diversité des éclats qui
sont obtenues pendant la taille de la
pierre et il ya beaucoup d' indices qui
nous permettent de dire que c'est que
c'est intentionnel de la barre et c'est
pas que c'est pas que ces comptes pas
que ça peut pas être confondus avec des
industries qui souffre est de manière
intentionnelle aussi passé
ces petits dans ces petits stages mais
de manière beaucoup moins planifié
complexe dans les objectifs
philou donc les archéologues savent très
bien les diagnostics et ça fait
longtemps que vous êtes au courant et en
plus ça fait longtemps que vous
l'utilisez à votre avantage pour
constituer justement l'évolution de la
commission donc en gros y avait pas de
quoi s'alarmer non il n'y avait pas de
quoi s'alarmer
la beauté de l'effet d'annoncé sur un
ton du coup aux dernières questions
en 2015 on a on a découvert au monal et
10 en afrique du sud à l'époque où il a
été annoncé il a été annoncé comme un
des premiers hominidés enterrer ses
morts est-ce que
ce que vous au niveau du registre
archéologiques vous voyez des sépultures
à ce qui a beaucoup de sépulture
attribué à homo sapiens heures en
afrique pas du tout en afrique il y en a
aucune
c'est curieux ce soir je vais il y a
juste aidé restent en général même sur
des sites on trouve ceux d'hier est
isolé on fait des fois des dents
quelques danses et de crabes aussi mais
des vrais sépulture comme par exemple le
champ de l'année ont certes alliant en
europe on en a pas de concert mais en
tout cas jusqu'à maintenant c'est
marrant ça que néandertal du cou et des
sépultures à une époque où sapiens n'en
avait pas on sait pas s'il n'en avait
pas la masse à pierre sang tout cas on
les retrouve pas d'accord c'est toujours
le même programme toujours le problème
on peut dire qu'en tout cas de ce qu'on
nous on voit ils font pas elles n'ont
pas de structure
après même j'en reviens à l'actuelle est
ce que nous montre l'actuel ce que nous
montre certaines populations actuelles
c'est que elle préfère s'éloigner du
groupe mourir seul dans la savane et
puis c'est faire manger par les animaux
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on laisse
aux pendus à la mère nature et c'est
vrai que si ce genre de rituel s'est
passé aussi omis de stone age et qui a
qui est très fortement lié à une
symbolique parce qu'il ya tout un monde
de croyance au tour 1
pas parce qu'il ya pas de ses coutures
qu'il n'y a pas de croyance derrière ces
rituels de mort qui laisse pas de traces
ou très peu ce qui faisait sa une au
soleil en effet on en a juste qu'une
trace ce qui ne leur en offrait pas une
star scénique qui nous échappe
totalement
et là il faut faire marcher aussi notre
imagination et sortir un petit peu des
fois de ce que l'on considère nous est
toujours inscrit au côté d'anouk hommes
comme faisant partie du monde de la voir
l'enterrement la génération et tout ça
en tout cas oui pour les silhouettes du
coup la sépulture c'est déjà face à une
manifestation particulière d'un rituel
funéraire mais il ya des tas de rituels
funéraires qui ne conduisent pas une
préservation un enterrement vous donc
c'est pas parce qu'on retrouve pas de
sépulture qu'il n'y a pas de rituel
absolument d'accord mais quand il y en a
il faut aussi accepter qu'elle existe et
c'est un petit peu le problème des fois
qu'il ya en europe puisqu'il ya eu
l'idée comme quoi le néanderthal
français yannick est très très bien il
ya un an qui est qui et qui reste collé
au resto ria européen avec certains en
tout cas qui change avec les nouvelles
générations mais qui continuent à croire
comme des retards était une sorte
d'abrutis brut est robuste et et violent
avec sa femme qui ne seraient pas
capables d'avoir justement des rituels
d'accompagnement
un mort et de sépulture justement et
donc il faut aussi accepter il faut
aussi les accepter ces découvertes quand
elles sont là et donc dans toute cette
complexité et en sachant dans cette
complexité notre travail c'est d'essayer
de ne pas désespérer essayer de prendre
ce qu'il ya de plus tangible dans tout
ça et d'émettre des hypothèses tout en
sachant qu'on peut pas on ne pourra
jamais retourner dans le temps pour voir
qu'est ce qui s'est réellement passé ne
vous fait des hypothèses
on apprend on s'appuie sur les preuves
les plus tangibles et surtout aussi on
accepte que les nouvelles technologies
mais nouvelles technologies les
nouvelles études les études de
l'ancienne collection nous permettent de
réviser tout le temps sans arènes
données en année
l'histoire de la préhistoire comme comme
on le voit pas ce que c'est une
discipline qui évolue sans cesse comme
une discipline scientifique très bientôt
que c'est sur ces bons mots que nous
allons nous laisser
merci beaucoup katia que nous avons
accordé cette interview elle va très
bien merci beaucoup à trajet
de t'intéresser quand même un petit peu
à l'archéologie et je crois que ces
échoppes sont sombrement fructueux merci
donc encore merci katia merci à tous de
nous avoir suivi donc on va vous mettre
plein de liens dans la description si
vous voulez en savoir plus il y en aura
en français et en anglais
je vous dis à très bientôt au revoir
[Musique]